Amanda Bally Onis from CBS their golf
reporter Amanda thanks for joining us
we're gonna give you the ceremonial
first pick oh okay well right into it I
am gonna go with the first overall pick
friend so Phil Mullen re whoa whoa
Francis Francesco model nominee okay
well I'm gonna go Rory McIlroy junior
the third uh Todd you're next
I'm gonna grab mr. jordan Spieth jordan
Spieth is off the board
McLovin how about Justin Rose whoo
that's you make it sound like that's a
real stretch there McLovin seat no
Connor I'm gonna go down the way down a
little ways I'm going hideki Matsuyama
with my first pick okay
you said 35 to one odds Paulie gets back
to back Jack I'm gonna go back to back
Brooks cap cut Tommy Fleetwood Dan
Fleetwood Mac love it fairway Jesus
Seaton O'Connor you're next he's not
officially called fairway Jesus is the
Amanda okay I'm going Xander chef oh all
right I like that pick
uh let's see McLovin at 16 1 how about
Tiger Woods okay all right just find the
root for no I like that fritzy
I'm gonna grab John ROM my second John
ROM I'm gonna go Dustin Johnson yeah I
was surprised he's still on the board
Amanda back to back I'm going with a man
who knows how to win here Phil Mickelson
okay all right Phil Mickelson you got
one more
oh and Marc Leishman oh he's gonna win
one one of these days yes yes he is
I am going to go Matt Kuchar yep
I'm gonna go couch okay let's see who's
next year of fritzy
I am going to grab mr. Ricky Fowler okay
Rick Fowler's off the board
McLovin you're next oh man what's the
penalty if you pick someone who's
already been picked Amanda what is it
you have to e3 cement Oh sandwiches in
one sitting
mmm about anyone go Tony female yet no
no you can go
Tony feed hell I like hell no matter who
we pick everybody goes oh man I'm gonna
thicken that's my guy yeah all right see
I'm going Kevin Kisner oh the kids
inator look at that see kiss you know
kiss nerve steady
not emotional doesn't hit it far just
hit it straight dreams payback for the
Francisco melon re not a Paulie I'm
going back to back down yeah I'm gonna
go Justin Thomas okay Jason day J day
okay then we go seating back down I'm
going Brandt Snedeker Sneyd great putter
all right McLovin oh boy there we go
Bubba yet no Bubba Watson all right
Fritzie I'm gonna take Bryson to
shambo's Lou okay I am going to go Paul
Casey Casey
Amanda the final pick of the 2019
masters belongs to you oh I am going to
go Brandon it great long hitter out of
South Africa I believe yeah play well
here all right so what's the buzz down
there what's the you know what's
trending at the Masters
what is Trent well I mean first of all
it's early week here at the Masters
there's nothing like it because
literally everybody is in a great new
system players have you sip patron it is
truly the happiest place on earth but
it's interesting to see on the practice
facility today the shift where you have
players like really informal chatting
away Monday Tuesday today it was all
business nobody was talking to each
other you know it will relax a little
bit with the par-3 contest but you can
tell these guys are ready to focus and
and get underway so I'm looking forward
to I mean we've seen Tiger out there a
lot Rory out there a lot builds and
grinding so it is you know all the short
game practice is happening right now and
the buzz is just overwhelmingly
everyone's happy to be here who needs to
win more than anybody in this field at
Augusta that's a good question yeah I
think the answer has to be Rory
fair right I mean he I think it's safe
to say nobody wants that green jacket
and no one's been closer to getting that
green jacket then Rory McIlroy so I I
think he is someone that has to just
play well all four rounds get it out of
his system put on that green jacket and
it would be really fun to see especially
after the close call last year and why
should we buy into Tiger this year he's
healthy finally I mean we could actually
finally say that with no reservations
and he's more relaxed you know just
seeing his mannerisms out there early we
see signing autographs for a really long
time he's smiling these he Justin's
relaxed and ready to go and I think as
you guys know in years past even when he
won you know 2013 those five times
everyone was still questioning his
health and I think for the first time in
a long time we don't have to question
that anymore it's just does he have what
it takes to get it done yet again and I
think you can never count agarwood that
well I think that is the difference
between this year in your staff I try to
tell people that you know that the
greens and you know how there
tilted the the terrain down like there's
so many things that you don't realize
how how much of a change it is when
you're in person as opposed to on TV and
I mentioned the holes are really close
together the sounds that echo off the
trees are louder than any other place
that you'll hear and you know you can
look at a green and you'll go oh my god
I don't know how they put on that like
the second green you'll go I don't even
know if you put it in a wrong place
you're just in trouble even twelve
twelve looks harmless when you're on the
tee and then you realize it's not
harmless you know it can you know
something can put up a ten there what's
the one thing that surprised you the
most at Augusta absolutely how difficult
of a walk it is you know in Kevin I've
even told me this morning we were
talking about the mental side of the
game and how you say mentally rested for
a test like this and he said Amanda
after I'm done playing four rounds at
the Masters I feel like I've played
three tournaments physically and
mentally so being able like you said
being here every patron says the same
thing the first time they had no idea
how silly it was and then you get to
those greens and there's no reprieve I
mean mentally it is just going to wear
you out because you really you can't
take any part of any whole off to
recover so it absolutely twelve is a
perfect example about 155 years down so
painless right so I'm so simple but I
did something with Frank Nobilo earlier
in the week and you said it looks
painless but it's actually like the
biggest pinterest so you could possibly
have out there very deceiving you know
beautiful but difficult so there's not
one hole out here that when you walk and
you see you're like okay and it's kind
of a gimme there's not what he gave me
out here at Augusta National Amanda have
a good week good luck and good luck in
our masters draft we appreciate you
joining us yes thank you good luck to
everyone but I'm secretly hoping I win
thank you there we go Amanda baglione
says CBS golf reporter for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV streamed for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app